and I see from your website that you
said that you had never really done
interviews before and so you googled
well how to interview people which I
thought was great what did you find out
I also - you took psychology in school
yeah I study psychology of acting
spiritual psychology of acting that was
that yeah and what it was very strange
because the only person that I
interviewed ever prior to this film was
in fact the Dalai Lama which was a bit
strange to have that on the resume for a
one time interview so and that's because
I was involved in the documentary with
some people and John Salley the
basketball player and Gustavo
Santaolalla the the music composer and
myself were sort of chronicled on a
journey across India through various
sort of religious places we were in you
know Hindu country we were in Sikh
country we were in Muslim country you
know and it culminated with meeting the
Dalai Lama and being able to ask him a
few questions and so that's the only
person I'd interviewed before and an
essay interviews - two questions but um
this was six months later we're thinking
well now we're going to you know travel
across America and all sorts of
questions and I just remember I think I
remember the one thing that stuck in my
mind was the how do you feel about you
know so how do you feel about the stay
at the country at the moment not like
what do you think of this or what do you
think of something better and then and
it it was the how do you feel or what
makes you feel that way I just remember
hanging onto those words in terms of
interviewing as I just remember the
googa in that mop house how do you feel
about what makes you feel that way okay
to remember that remember that but
regardless of whatever I may or may not
have discovered on googling the
interviewing technique the one thing
that was important to me at that time
was I didn't want to go in there with my
own agenda I didn't want to be sitting
there you know no matter who I am
wanting to sort of put my whole agenda
on - well what I feel about the country
and how
I think people are thinking I just
wanted to be like okay so you're an NRA
member okay so how do you feel about you
know the state of things how do you feel
about blah blah blah and just no matter
what people said no matter how uplifting
or inspiring or subversive or
controversial it might have been just to
be like okay so you feel that way um
what what makes you feel that way you
know how do what what do you what do you
take from that and and you know just
being open and receptive and not trying
to put too much of my stuff on to it and
the times that was a bit challenging but
ultimately much more interesting cuz I
can sit with my cell I know I think all
day like itse wherever I want to sit and
talk about why I think terribly boring
they're much more interesting if I know
oh gosh so you think that way how why is
that then I just keep people just keep
opening them up you know and then then
we had some interesting interviews it's
almost like being a therapist in some
ways well I don't know if I'd make a
very good therapist but um it's it was
certainly you know people do like to
talk and all we did on those because it
obviously was a bit strange I guess in
the middle of Arkansas in Australian in
a an Englishman you know rolling out and
getting skinny well make a decision
making this documentary about you know
America dilemma well here you boy where
you come from yeah I don't know what you
do little but I found that you know if
you just look people in the eye and just
safely what it is you're doing and be
lovely to talk to you you know people
are okay and then you just initially ask
them how's life around here and you know
people become quite open for a good
chitchat so that's what we found
you